[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are we gonna have a hollywood minute
here seaton
i i gotta get to florio but uh you're
teasing me here with gwyneth paltrow
well she made a pretty powerful
admission
uh about some of the sort of the lows
that she hit during uh
quarantine oh okay are you ready
no no no no i gotta get to florio i mean
he's really busy
it's it's a stunning unless mike florian
wants to hear about gwyneth paltrow mike
i'm going to leave this up to you we can
talk football or we can
work in gwyneth paltrow dan i will not
be able to function properly over the
course of this interview if i don't know
okay what happened and i went and i
believe you're being sincere mike
uh yes well this news broke i think
maybe
a day or two ago um but it's uh it's
just taken me now to emotionally
be prepared to to bring this to you guys
but apparently during quarantine gwyneth
paltrow
broke down and ate bread oh my god
actual bread yeah carbs and all
back to you did she announce this like
like a revelation that's how low things
got she actually ate breakfast but the
crust and everything yes oh my god
my gwyneth she was really although when
you said she ate bread i thought you
said she ate brad
no and i'm gone
[Laughter]
now let's bring in mike florio pro
football talk live co-host
uh let me start with tim tebow i'm i'm
curious
you know you had chris collinsworth
podcast with urban meyer and
chris asked him and urban basically
saying i haven't made a decision yet
when does he have to make a decision on
tim tebow joining the 90-man roster
let me just first say that during
quarantine on a nightly basis
i took a large piece of bread
soaked it in bourbon lit it on fire
and swallowed it whole so take that
when you look at the clip of what urban
meyer said to chris collinsworth i mean
at one point he says
hey let's give it a shot well but we
haven't decided to do it yet i
i don't i don't i don't get it dan i
don't know if this is a trial balloon
if they're they're stung by what
happened with the iowa strength coach
that they had on the
payroll for like a day before urban
meyer realized this isn't like college
football where you just do whatever you
want to do
this is a gimmick this is a sideshow
urban meyer is trying to sell it as
something
other than that it is an effort to sell
jerseys it's an effort to sell tickets
they can sign whenever they want to sign
them and i think part of it is
frankly they got to figure out what
they're going to do with gardner minshew
because he's wearing tebow's number
and so that's that's a reason to wait
because you want to sell the 15 jerseys
right out of the gates you don't want to
have a back order of 15 jerseys and you
don't want to have something awkward
where he wears number 16 then number 15.
but
um i i i feel like it's gonna happen
it's just a matter of when
and i i guess the one small sliver is
the possibility that urban meyer gets
enough pushback internally that he
realizes this isn't college football
i'm not going to be able to make this
fly in the locker room because there's
going to be guys giving him the side eye
in the locker room
saying are you serious a guy hasn't been
in the nfl since 2012 in a regular
season game
never played tight end he had one snap
at tight end it did not go well
and and he's he's going to get one of
these jobs that there are
hundreds of guys out there trying to get
these jobs get out of here with that i
feel like he's going to have to deal
with that internally
but it's the 90-man roster that's
that's different for me if it got down
to the 53-man roster
oh it will i i think whatever you think
if he gets on the 90-man roster he's
going to make the 53-man roster
well why is he on the 90-man roster
what's what's the point of giving one of
90 roster spots
in one of the most competitive sports in
the world when there are guys
every year coming out of the college
level who are good enough to play at the
nfl level
and they're dying for a spot on the 90
man roster you're taking that 90th spot
and you're giving it to a guy who you
should just hire to be an assistant
coach
make up a title for him if you want him
in the building if you want to give your
friend a job do that
don't give him one of the 90 spots where
the guys are competing to be one of the
53 i think what's going to happen is
he'll end up on the practice squad and
they will elevate him on a regular basis
to one of those two extra spots
where you can take practice squad guys
and make it a 55-man roster
and potentially potentially end up
uh you know dressing getting a gimmick
play thrown his way catching a touchdown
pass
fans are happy jerseys are sold i i just
think that
you're not doing this dance with tim
tebow now unless you have plans for
september and i think urban meyer has
plans for september or he wouldn't be
wasting his time on it now
why does tim tebow bring about anger
well
i i i look i yesterday people
immediately started to make the
connection with colin kaepernick because
kaepernick's been out four years and
right now the strongest argument for not
giving kaepernick a chance is he hasn't
played in four years
well here's a guy who hasn't played in
eight years and he's going to
change to a position he refused to play
back when the quarterback thing
started to to fizzle out for him but it
occurred to me
this is very simple no one was going to
give her tim tebow a chance urban meyer
is the one coach
who was going to sign tim tebow just
like jim harbaugh is the one coach who
would sign colin kaepernick
because he's been praising kaepernick
the last four years if harbaugh ended up
being the coach in jacksonville
maybe kaepernick gets an opportunity but
tebow gets an opportunity
because it's the one coach who would
give him one and i just think it's this
idea
dan that it started with the baseball
thing for me i had no problem with him
playing in the nfl he's a first round
draft pick josh mcdaniels rolled the
dice and it kind of worked you know he
got to the playoffs i mean
horribly inaccurate figured a way to win
close games
from time to time magical run in 2011
but you know there's a certain point
where you just gotta you just gotta you
gotta move on
and and if you don't move on you're
you're you're and i got no problem with
it i'm a capitalist
the mets thing was about making money
yeah and i feel like this thing's about
making money so don't
don't tell me it's about football when
it's about making money because i think
it's about
jacksonville jerseys tickets excitement
and not about football if i said urban
meyer is either going to be really good
or really bad no middle ground
what would you take really bad just
because history
tells us other than jimmy johnson you
know it seems like every few years
there's a college coach who comes to the
nfl and he's going to revolutionize the
game
and the media lines up to apply lips to
his buttocks in the event that he is
jimmy johnson
right oh whoa oh this could be great oh
greg sean oh he's going to be great
chip kelly oh he's going to be great
he's going to revolutionize the game
nope
uh who who was the other one yeah
spurrier saban i mean they're all one
after another here's a guy
and i'll believe it when i see it if if
you're going to be jimmy johnson you got
to prove to me you're jimmy johnson and
until then there's only one jimmy
johnson that's how i look at it
and and and i feel like there's so many
in our business
that are falling all over themselves to
assume that this is the next vince
lombardi
i i it makes me inclined to go the other
way too
and uh we'll see we'll see it's it's a
hell of a laboratory experiment
and from the jaguars perspective every
other thing they've tried
for the past 20 years hasn't worked so
they may as well try this he's mike
florio pro football talk live
co-host with chris sims um
i'm wondering if the commissioner can
call the packers
before they before they do the the
schedule release
like if you're running a league
you like you have the packers opening
weekend that 425 slot that that's fox's
big game
and the other game is denver against the
giants the team mentioned
as the landing spot for aaron rodgers if
he doesn't stay in green bay do you
think the commissioner calls
teams not just the packers to inquire
about certain things like a situation
like that
to help when they release the schedule
look i i don't know if the commissioner
sits down with a notepad
and a to-do list and i'm going to call
mark murphy today and talk about aaron
rodgers but i suspect they have
ways of getting information whether it's
three levels down but they they they get
the best information
they can what's going on here what do
you think is going to happen
they need that information packers
chiefs biggest game of the year
potentially other than buccaneers
patriots
you got to put that game late enough in
the season they can be flexed out of 425
or flexed out of sunday night football
if that's where it would end up i mean
you don't want it to be locked into
monday night football you don't want it
to be in a hard spot where you can't
move it
because you may or may not have aaron
rodgers so i think there are ways to
protect yourself against it
but yeah i those how do you not have
those conversations when you have access
to the individuals involved
and these are legitimate business
considerations where are we going to put
these marquee games
let's take away the buccaneers and the
cowboys give me the must-see match-up
in week one wow uh steelers bills
i'm surprised that's a one o'clock game
i really am a couple of
playoff teams from last year with a lot
of continuity i mean with the saints
packers you know you're getting one new
quarterback
in new orleans whether it's taysom hill
or jameis winston it's not like drew
brees is back
you got ben roethlisberger in what
likely will be his final year going to
buffalo
to take on josh allen uh the steelers
going all in
the bill is trying to rectify how their
season ended
i think that's the best game of week one
and you could argue it's even better
than cowboys bucks
yeah but i think this might be because
it's buffalo
and they're at one o'clock that maybe
steelers of course are a national draw
i don't know if the buffalo bills are a
national draw if if this game was in
pittsburgh then maybe it's a 425 game
but
i don't know it just feels like maybe
buffalo is still not graduated to that
must-see tv
what excites you more steelers bills or
ravens raiders
steelers and the bills yeah but now the
raiders
new stadium i think there's a
sensitivity to letting these stadiums
absolutely all year absolutely this is
the first time there's actually going to
be human beings other than the players
and the coaches and the officials
in allegiant stadiums so it's got to
have a prime spot
kind of quiet on the desean watson front
here
very quiet what's that what's that mean
it means that they're working on a
settlement of the 22 cases it's the only
it's the only reasonable conclusion at
this point and
look it was nearly three weeks ago where
the lawyers were in court
accusing the other parties each side of
destroying evidence
and there were social media posts dan
and there were press conferences
it was ugly and it was nasty the plug
doesn't mutually get
pulled on those tactics in the court of
public opinion
unless there's something happening
behind the scenes and if they can get
these cases settled to the satisfaction
of everyone involved
i think desean watson gets traded and i
wrote last night that i think the two
main destinations for him would be the
dolphins or the eagles and i think the
eagles are a team that should never be
discounted in this
uh because they are desperate to get a
franchise quarterback and yes they want
to go all in with jalen hurts this year
but if desean watson who's already
proven himself would fall into their
laps
i think they would do it i keep thinking
the washington football team
i think that's possible but the only
problem is we know what's happened off
the field with the washington football
team
with cheerleaders with the owner and
i i i think that's a molotov cocktail if
you bring deshawn watson into
a situation like that even if you're
making a great point
and he's going to get suspended even if
he gets all these cases resolved today
you can't not suspend him with 22 of
these claims alleging sexual misconduct
during massages when
ben roethlisberger served four games in
2010 with two allegations
of sexual misconduct so you can't look
the other way if you're the nfl it's got
to be a four or six game suspension some
people i've talked to around
the teams not the league office but the
teams are thinking that's what it would
be
i don't think there's going to be any
hesitation to trade for him
once these cases are resolved because if
the cases aren't resolved
then what you're trading for is a guy
who's going to be on the commissioner
exempt list
until the cases are resolved you know
there's going to be a suspension you
assume there's going to be one
you trade for him he serves the
suspension and then he comes back
by halloween and you've got him for the
rest of this year and more importantly
for the rest of his career if you can
keep him happy
and uh and if you can work it out from a
cap standpoint here we are in the middle
of may if you
were betting on aaron rodgers where
he'll be in september
i think he's gonna find a way to come
back and act like
what's everybody looking at i mean is
there a booger i'm unaware of why is
everyone staring at me why does everyone
ask me all these questions what's the
big deal
i think he's going to do that dan we've
seen him do that before you know he'll
he'll light the fuse he'll run away and
after the explosion
he comes back and he chastises everyone
for noticing the explosion
i think that's what he's going to do and
he's going to blame us me you
everyone who's made a big deal about it
we're just looking for clicks we're
looking for views
we're looking to make money off of his
name when he knew damn well
that he could have ended all of this
with tarico at the kentucky derby
two days into it he had a chance to go
on camera and say this is all overblown
this is all fake this is nothing i'll be
there
i think he's going to find a way to come
back because he's got no other options
because i don't think the packers at
this point are going to trade him
but does he enjoy this i don't know
i don't know you know it's a dynamic too
though mike like
the dynamic i see from players from time
to time goes like this
hey everybody look at me what the hell
are you looking at
right
well he can always retire and do
jeopardy 30 million dollars to retire
dan no i know i know when people seek
all of it back
yes but i when people say oh he'll
retire and do jeopardy
there's no given that he'll get to do
jeopardy
and they're not going to pay him 30
million dollars peter king made a great
point a couple of weeks ago
on one hand aaron rodgers has no
hesitation at all
to tell the world i want to be the host
of jeopardy no nuance
no ambiguity no beautiful mystery
nothing
i want this job as it comes to his
football career he won't tell us a damn
thing
he's speaking in riddles and enigmas and
clues and whispers and
tell just tell us what you want aaron
what's so hard about telling people what
you want when you've already proven that
you have the capacity
well i said that to shefty like come on
like aaron owes it
to people and then chef dee's like no he
doesn't i go yes he does
chef he's getting himself in line for
the scoop of what happens next with
aaron
dan come on come on dan chef shefty's
taking every bullet he can for aaron
that whole thing about
that he's the one who chu
bull crap rogers wanted that out there
shefty took the bullet so that when the
next move comes
shefty's the one who gets it rogers
wanted that out there the day that it
hit not that wasn't chef he's sitting
back working a chess board that was
rogers
work in the chess board that may have
included shefty as one of the pawns
you should have chefty on your show oh
man he's welcome anytime
we tell it like it is baby i'm too old
to give a crap anymore dan
life's too short to tiptoe and kiss ass
and
pretend to play the game do you think
you could take adam schefter
oh i could take him oh i could take him
he's in pretty good shape
i will only pick a fight with people
that i know that i could beat up
really so yeah which is why i'd never
pick a fight with you
absolutely absolutely yes paulie
it's height and reach yes yes dan that's
already breaking this one down now
florio is in good shape he's got
good sized arms they're sneaky covers
them up a lot schefter's a thick guy
i don't know how athletic is her if he
could fight but he's a northwestern guy
not the toughest school
well just do the tail of the tape i'll
show up anytime any place for the
measurements
for the tail of the tape that's all i'm
saying
that's all i'm saying thank you bud
thank you man that's mike florio pro
football talk live
go